Can you go over why not PPL one more time in the fight?
Yeah, okay, so Josh, he's asking,
how do you get rid of the PPL objective?
So what I do during the screencast
and also during the close is I say,
all right, so as far as the deal goes,
we don't do commission, just so you know,
the reason why is there's literally
no skin in the game for you.
It doesn't work out.
Nope, like you're not gonna have any incentive
to follow up with leads.
I don't wanna track it.
You don't wanna track it.
It's a waste of time.
I don't do that, okay?
And I'll say, and I always say that,
say what we used to do when we first started
is we watched Home Advisor and we thought,
now maybe we'll try the paper lead model.
And we did it because we thought it would be really easy
to sign business owners up
because they only pay for what they get.
But what happens, and this happens every single time,
Mr. Business Owner, and without fail, okay?
And this is why we do not do this anymore.
We haven't done it for years is there is a threshold.
So let's say that I'm sending you 10 leads
at a hundred bucks a piece just for easy math, okay?
And by the way, when you say that example,
use a high number so that they're already like condition
that it's high.
So let's say that I'm sending you 20 leads
at a hundred bucks a piece.
You're cool paying me two grand, okay?
Two grand within your budget, 2000, 2000, 2000.
But what happens when, Mr. Business Owner,
all of a sudden I go from 20 leads to 50?
You know what's gonna happen?
I'll tell you what's gonna happen.
You're gonna start complaining about leads
because you don't have the manpower to run 50 leads, okay?
So now you're gonna start not wanting
to go to certain zip codes.
You're not gonna wanna take certain jobs.
You're gonna wanna hire and raise your minimum price.
And all of a sudden, I'm not gonna make any more money
and you're gonna be complaining about it.
And we're gonna literally have this back
and forth every single month.
And you're gonna take out your red pencil
and I'm gonna take out mine.
It's a absolute headache.
So we do not do that anymore, period.
What we found is a lot better is we just do a flat rate.
And what happens is every single month,
it's the exact same.
We usually charge per week, by the way.
In December, this is a great place to introduce this,
by the way, in December, just so you know,
it is gonna be a little bit slower because it's December.
But the cool part is, is in the spring and the summer
and the fall, when it's higher than normal,
you don't get a knock on your door like,
hey, let's raise the price.
So that's why we do the flat fee.
So let me show you how we came up with your flat fee,
Mr. Business Hunter.
Here's what I call the lead value calculator.
Whatiseleadworth.com.
There you go, Mr. Josh Savage.
Boom.